welcome before we get too far into this
evening's event I would like to ask one
of our chaplain father Roger BR to
pronounce an
invocation Heavenly Father we praise you
always for your goodness we ask you for
your grace tonight to open our hearts
and Minds that we may learn in new ways
to praise your your love for us and to
establish your kingdom
we ask this through your beloved Son
Christ Our Lord amen blessed is our Lord
at all times now always and
forever so I hope you'll allow me to
just take a few moments to introduce you
to the
college I don't need to do a headcount
uh to tell you this is the largest crowd
we've had for an evening event Thomas
Moore college is just over 30 years old
one of the young Liars colleges in the
country one of the oldest campuses in
the country it's an 18th century 1726
Farm some of you noticed when you came
in but the center of the campus 18th
century buildings I'm sure a number of
you are thinking right now what I
actually noticed was that you have 18th
century
parking 18th century
lighting Charlie mckenny beneath the
exit sign is the vice president of
development if anyone would like to
endow lights or parking lot it's a great
naming
opportunity college has had an excellent
reputation for years for its commitment
to the humanities and that's witnessed
by very high percentage of our graduates
60% of our graduates go on to law school
and graduate school it's extremely high
um if you stay and I encourage you to
stay for the reception afterwards you'll
also get a good sense of the college by
meeting some of our students during the
reception and I again I would encourage
that in addition to its commitment to
Humanities The Core Curriculum here the
integrated curriculum here it's not
simply a Core Curriculum takes the
students through four years of
humanities Natural Science mathematics
Classical Languages economics politics
literature philosophy and theology as a
Catholic institution I suppose I can't
say that um as our particular kind a
Catholic institution we are completely
loyal to the magisteria of the church
all our students during their sophomore
year study in Rome as well and we
usually don't film things this is being
filmed now so perhaps some of the
students in Rome will see this today is
Dr connell's birthday
students happy birthday Paul got this is
a
you typically we would have 6 12 guests
at an evening lecture so this is
extraordinary I the guest minut is
there's around 100 guests number of
guests May in fact exceed the number of
students again I welcome you debate is
something that my colleague behind me
John Z has been promoting over the last
few years it is one of the ways that we
pursue in common the faculty and the
students together one of the ways we
pursue wisdom I hope that you enjoy the
EXP experience tonight and now I'll hand
things over to John professor of
literature and author many books and our
writer and residence thank
you very proud to have with me two of
the most distinguished writers in their
fields alive uh the most distinguished
Catholic philosophical writer in in
English I would say um no false modesty
uh and uh the leading expert on Jihad
and political Islam Robert Spencer um I
am the writer and residence here I teach
the rhetoric classes and the literature
classes um I'm I also write and edit
books this book happens to have essays
by Mr Spencer and Dr creef in it it's
called disorientation it's the 14
heresies that steal students faith in
college and there'll be some copies
downstairs if any of you are interested
in getting it there'll also be some uh
Mr Spencer will be signing some copies
of his books downstairs at the reception
so it's fun to have one chapter of my
book at battling the other chapter uh Mr
Spencer wrote the essay on
multiculturalism Mr creef wrote the
essay on progressivism and it seems to
me that their views in the book lead
into the debate tonight one of them
thinks progressivism is a greater danger
secularism modernism the legacy of the
Enlightenment is a greater danger to the
church than the alternative religion of
Islam Mr Spencer believes that bad as
the as the enlightenment might be there
are even worse things so I think it will
be a very interesting exchange uh M Mr
creef has written a book called between
Allah and Jesus uh it's the third book
He's written exploring the interface and
the interactions and the commonalities
and divergences between
Christianity and Islam it's a recent
book what's the name of the
publisher um let's see yeah let's hold
it
up iniversity press I encourage you to
pick it up it's as as like all of his
books it's beautifully written and very
winning actually it's the only one in
which uh Islam and Christianity are
compared oh really the other two
including a refutation moral relativism
just happen to have characters from my
forthcoming novel one of which is a
Muslim and the other of CHR I see okay
all right sorry about that I I thought
it was a longer last I just wanted to
take that opportunity to plug my
forthcoming not
absolutely absolutely plug away plug
away uh Mr cre is also professor of
philosophy at Boston College author of
more than 45 books I've read a large
percentage of them um and enjoyed them
immensely and I'm very honored and proud
he was able to make it Mr Spencer is
author of 10 books yes 10 books um way
to catch up
but he also he's also uh the editor of
jihad watch.com where he writes 10 posts
a day so I think if you add them up they
might be a sort of they would reach the
moon all right good so uh the format
tonight is fairly straightforward um the
the we structured the debate the way we
structure our other debates on campus
the Edmund Campion debate Society is the
student debate group where we we have
Oxford style parliamentary debates on
topics of interest in the intellectual
life our last one was resolve that the
American Revolution does not meet the
criteria for just War according to St
Thomas aquinus but the uh the American
revolutionaries won that debate by by
two votes um
so the previous debate was about whether
prohibition should be passed and each
debate is set in the time so the debate
and prohibition pretended to be 1917 the
debate for the American Revolution
pretended to be 1776 July 7th a bunch of
Catholics in Baltimore debating the
wisdom of joining of the Revolution well
this one is said in the
present we don't have to pretend we
don't have to pretend we're in 7th
Century Arabia or 15th century Byzantium
Islam and the West are facing each other
they are
interacting some sometimes in a bloody
way sometimes perhaps in a creative way
tonight we're going to figure we're
going to try to figure out whether or
not there there is a hopeful resolution
for orthodox Islam and the Contemporary
West and Catholicism three different
things um we our our topic is resolved
that the only good Muslim is a bad
Muslim a a line I think I took from your
book and uh Mr Spencer will be speaking
in the affirmative so he speaks first
for 20 minutes
then Dr creef responds for 20 minutes
then there'll be about 20 minutes of
them asking each other questions then
I'll pose them each a question or two
and then after after a bathroom break
you will there'll be opportunities for
questions from the audience so Mr
Spencer would you like to lead off thank
you very much thank you all for coming
and thank you to everyone at Thomas
Moore college for hosting this I think
this is a discussion that uh needs to be
had in the Public Square and is all too
often all lighted ignored and uh not
held where it should be and so I hope
that uh this will perhaps bring some
needed attention to these questions it's
a great honor for me to be appearing
with Dr CRA who was my professor many
hundreds of years ago and uh at that
time we used to uh spend quite a bit of
time uh outside class actually uh
playing pingpong and he was so much
better at it than I was that he would
play on his
knees and uh still win but uh I'm hoping
perhaps at the end of tonight we'll both
still be standing at least figuratively
in any case uh Dr cr's book between
Allah and Jesus is one that I read with
great interest and I certainly see what
is the motive behind what he's trying to
do in it in so far if as I understand it
correctly and why he would want to
portray Islam in this manner now the
question before us is somewhat
uncomfortable it even seems kind of
insulting to say the only good Muslim is
a bad Muslim uh especially in a context
where we have uh uh a Catholic College
hosting a debate and it's as if one of
the debate participants namely myself is
saying that uh religious people of a
certain kind should be discouraged from
holding to their religion it seems like
something that other religious people
should not be in the position of saying
and certainly it is uh something that
most people would reject out of hand on
the face of it and say obviously this is
not true because we all know that uh the
the people who are committing violence
in the name of Islam are twisting and
hijacking the religion and if they only
go back to the teachings of the Quran
and of Muhammad the prophet of Islam
then this problem of terrorism and many
other in attendant problems of Islamic
supremacism would have
aness and I think it's in that spirit
that uh Dr crafe wrote his book uh
certainly it is something devoutly to be
wished that people of Good Will of all
faiths could find some kind of common
Accord and work on that common Accord
for their shared values we have even
seen that happen between the Catholic
church and Islamic countries at the
United Nations against various anti-life
initiatives and so this is something
that uh many people have great hope for
the great danger in holding such a hope
is that we fall into wishful
thinking and project upon other
religious people values that we
ourselves May hold or that people of
certain religious Traditions May hold
and that therefore we assume are held by
people of all other religious Traditions
when actually that's not the case and
unfortunately I must say with regret
that I did find a great deal of that
kind of thing in this particular book
the uh idea for example is posited
several times in the book by the Muslim
character who I think it's fair to say
is the hero of the story uh he is like
Dr Craig's books which uh are all
marvelous and fluidly written and very
persuasive great influence on my own uh
development he often has dialogues
between various characters but you can
generally tell uh what site he's on and
what he believes to be the truth and in
this in this particular book this these
truths or these uh uh things that Dr
crafe is positing to be the truths are
enunciated most often by the Muslim
character many times he says that Jihad
is an interior spiritual struggle now
that is something that does exist in
Islamic tradition but when we are
speaking about the idea of should Muslim
piety be encouraged should Muslim people
be encouraged to be more rigorous and
more devout and more fervent in their
religious observance we have to go back
to the Wellsprings to the texts and
teachings of the Quran and Muhammad the
prophet of Islam because he is held up
in the Quran as 33: 211 calls him or the
excellent example of conduct and in
Islamic tradition he is even exalted in
many places as Al insan Cil the perfect
man and in in practice in Islamic
tradition even though Muhammad is uh
rebuked several times in the Quran
notably in chapter 80 for his
sinfulness in practice in Islamic
tradition Muhammad essentially is the
Touchstone of all behavior and if he did
it then it's good and right and ought to
be imitated now that's important for the
present question because when we have
the Muslim character saying Jihad is an
interior spiritual struggle he is in
fact actually putting himself in the
position of contradicting the words and
example of Muhammad and the words of the
Quran itself there's an entire chapter
of the Quran chapter 8 called alfal The
Spoils of War there are no Spoils of War
in an interior spiritual struggle
there's no booty to be captured there
are no slave girls to be distributed
among the Warriors and yet that chapter
of the Quran and others actually
contains instructions for doing just
that kind of thing and a fifth of the
spoils are reserved for the prophet
himself he took part in these wars he
fought actually 78 battles during his
career as a prophet and 77 were
offensive in nature the Quran does not
teach that Jihad is its interior
spiritual struggle the Quran almost
unanimously when it speaks of jihad when
it uses the Arabic word Jihad in its
various forms which means struggle and
of course struggle in Arabic has just as
many connotations as struggle does in
English you can struggle to quit smoking
or to lose weight you can struggle
against communism or uh have States
struggling against one another so it is
also in Islam but the primary meaning of
the word Jihad in the Quran is
unmistakably Warfare and the uh Muslim
hero of Dr cra's book further says that
Muhammad never fought against Christians
and Jews unless he did so in a defensive
manner that unfortunately is also
factually false in as a matter of fact
the last battle of his career right
before he died Muhammad went to tabuk
which was an outpost a Byzantine
Imperial Outpost in Northern Arabia or
Southern Syria depending on where you
want to put the border and uh he he went
to fight a Christian Garrison there of
the Byzantine Eastern Roman Empire uh he
didn't actually find them there they
left whether they left in order to avoid
fighting him or whether they left
because they didn't know he was coming
and didn't care and left for their own
reasons we don't know in any case he was
not able to fight them but unfortunately
he left in chapter 9 of the Quran
numerous
teachings which of course are all
conveyed as divine revelation that
cannot be questioned and has to be
obeyed by any Pious and observant Muslim
he left instructions to wage offensive
Warfare against Jews and Christians
particularly in chapter 9: 29 which
tells Muslims to fight against those who
do not obey Allah and his messenger and
do not forbid what he has forbidden in
other words they don't follow the
strictures of Islamic
law even if they are of the people of
the book which is the quranic
designation primarily for Jews and
Christians until they pay the gizia
which is a tax that's what the word
means in Arabic with willing submission
and feel themselves
subdued that verse became the foundation
for an elaborate superstructure of laws
that are still part of Islamic jurist
Prudence they are still part of Islamic
political law that islamists that Jihad
terrorists and that any Islamic
supremacist wants to impose over the
world today these laws mandate that
non-muslims of the people of the book
must pay a special tax from which
Muslims are exempt as a matter of fact
you can pretty much correlate in Islamic
history the strength and the aggression
and the rise of the great Islamic
empires of the past with the size of the
Jewish and Christian communities that
were subjugated within those Empires and
were paying for that Imperial expansion
when those communities were exhausted
economically then the Islamic Empires
went into
decline this is an absolute correlation
that recurs again and again and again
the Christians and Jews in Muslim lands
were subjugated in accord with that
section of the verse the last part until
they pay the gizia with willing
submission and feel themselves subdued
they never enjoyed equality of rights
with
Muslims they were denied the right to
build new houses of worship or to repair
old ones they were denied the right to
hold authority over Muslims so that Jews
and Christians were relegated to the
most menial and degrading jobs in the
society they were subject to various
other humiliating and discriminatory
regulations now this is as I say I
cannot emphasize enough still part of
Islamic law this is not one sect or one
school or one group that's heretical
that has made this part of their
teaching this is universal among all the
sects and the schools of jurist prudence
that are recognized as mainstream and
Orthodox by fellow
Muslims they all teach that you cannot
find one that does not teach the
necessity to wage war against
unbelievers to subjugate them under the
rule of Islamic law and they are working
as a matter of fact Hamas in Gaza has
announced its intention to once it's
fully Consolidated its power to impose
that system of dimude and subjugate the
Christians that remain there under its
under its uh institutionalized forms of
discrimination gangs in Baghdad they did
not have governing authority to be sure
but they terrorized the Christian
Community which as I'm sure you know is
uh terrorized on a more or less daily
basis and there was just another
massacre in a church the other day they
were knocking on doors in Baghdad last
year and demanding payment of the jiza
this tax which was essentially uh it
amounts to protection money that you pay
it and then you don't get killed but you
don't pay it or you transgress some of
the other laws that are set out for
these subjugated peoples and then your
life is
forfeit these things are still part of
the agenda for Islamic jihadists today
the Islamic jihadists coming back to the
thesis the the the question being
debated here tonight Islamic jihadists
routinely portray themselves within the
Muslim communities
worldwide and among peaceful Muslims as
being the most Pious most observant in
other words best Muslims
available they are in other words the
Muslims Who present themselves as being
the true the pure Muslims as a matter of
fact the worldwide salafi movement
that's what it's all dedicated to is
restoring the purity of Islam as they
see it Hassan Alana the founder of the
Muslim Brotherhood founded the
Brotherhood in 1928 after Kamal Ataturk
abolished the caliphate which was the
supernational symbol of the unity the
supernational unity of the
Muslims that transcended all national
boundaries Ataturk abolished the
caliphate in 1924 Hassan Alana
established the Muslim Brotherhood in
1928 in Egypt as a direct reaction to
the abolition of the caliphate because
he believed that without the political
aspects of
Islam that have never been considered to
be separable from the religious
individual aspects of spiritual
observance in any Islamic tradition that
those without the political aspect of
Islam that had been damaged by the
abolition of the caliphate Islam was not
being fully observed in the world and he
dedicated the Muslim Brotherhood which
is the direct forefather of Hamas and
Al-Qaeda and other terrorist groups as
well as many uh pseudo moderate groups
in the United States today like the
Council on American Islamic relations
and so on he was dedicating it to
restoring what he saw as the fullness of
Islamic observance as the true
observance of Islamic piety which
involved the subjugation of unbelievers
violence against them if they
resisted and the establishment of
Muslims as a special class who would
enjoy rights that the other groups in
the society did not
enjoy these things are represented
around the world today in the Islamic
World in Muslim communities in the west
as well as being part of what it means
to be a good Muslim
they make their appeal to Peaceful
Muslims they justify their own actions
of Terror or supremacism and they make
recruits among peaceful Muslims by
representing themselves as being the
embodiment of authentic Muslim
observance now obviously there are
Muslims who do not consider that acts of
terrorism or violence or the supremacist
attempts to impose Islamic law over
non-muslims they don't believe that that
is part of their Islamic piety and
certainly I applaud them and I wish
there were more of them in so far as
they're
sincere they are however universally
worldwide on the defensive today they
are represented as the bad Muslims by
their fellow Muslims who are pointing to
the texts of the Quran and the teachings
of Muhammad to portray themselves as
being the ones who were in the right and
so the Muslims who we could look to with
hopes of Reform the Muslims who we would
look to with hopes of they being our
allies they are the ones who are
considered to be the bad Muslims
generally in the Islamic community it
must also further be stated
unfortunately that there is
no theological system in Islam there is
no sect there is no group within Islam
that has formulated
a comeback a a a an an understanding a
construction of Islamic theology based
on the Quran that makes a case to reject
violence and supremacism and the
subjugation of unbelievers doesn't exist
there are many
individuals who are working against it
but there is no group that we can point
to and say ah they're the ones we need
to work
with in other words they have not
formulated any kind of convincing
comeback the texts are not on their side
there are peaceful pacifistic texts in
the Quran Dr CRA quotes many of them in
his book he does not unfortunately quote
the violent ones to which I alluded
before and I mentioned one of them
specifically another one for example is
chapter 8:60 part of that alanf fall
Spoils of War Chapter that directs
Muslims to strike Terror into the hearts
of the enemies of Allah now you can say
well that doesn't have to do with modern
terrorism that's Terror in a much
broader sense but unfortunately modern
terrorists can and do point to that
verse and say that's what we're doing
that's why we're doing what we're doing
we're striking Terror into the hearts of
the enemies of Allah the peaceful
passages according to mainstream Islamic
theologians and to the preponderance of
Islamic theological
tradition do not take precedence over
the violent passages the peaceful
passages generally were revealed earlier
in Muhammad's career he was a prophet
for 23 years over those 23 years he
received Revelations from from God which
were collected in the Quran early in his
career when he was in Mecca he had a
small band of followers facing a very
powerful Pagan Arab establishment of his
own tribe the Kay in
Mecca that's when he was saying you have
your say to the unbelievers you have
your religion and we have ours you don't
worship what we worship and we don't
worship what you worship and essentially
let's just leave each other alone that's
chapter 109 of the
Quran the unfortunate fact is that when
he later moved in the Hijra or the
hijera the Hijra to Medina and became
for the first time a political and
military leader the te tenor of the
konic revelations began to change and
the violence began to be began to be
taught and began to be carried out by
Muhammad himself now mainstream Islamic
theologians and the preponderance of
Islamic theological tradition teaches
that the if there is a disagreement
between two passages in in the
Quran then one of the chief ways to
understand which one takes precedence
for our own day is which one came later
chronologically in Muhammad's career
unfortunately for us the violence comes
later and thus is considered under the
principle of alas or abreg to have been
cancel to cancel out the peaceful
passages or the peaceful passages only
apply when Muslims are a small group
like the meccan Muslims were in in the
first stage of Muhammad's career so in
other words they're a small group
they're powerless then they teach
tolerance and nonviolence but later
gaining power gaining in numbers the
other parts begin to kick
in and you have the violence and the
supremacism begin to apply I believe
right now we're in the state of
transition in the United States where
we're moving from one to the other and
there's a great deal more aggression and
a great deal more assertiveness this in
Islamic communities and by Islamic
jihadists against the United States
because they see that we are at a
Tipping Point so they can move away from
tolerance a third of the actually over a
third of the attacks against the United
States or attempted Jihad attacks
against the United States that have
happened since 911 over a third of them
have happened in the last
year which means there's been a sharp
uptick in the last year and so this
indicates that
we are dealing with a group that
considers itself to be acting in
complete Accord with the dictates of
Islamic teaching and thus to say that we
want to encourage Islamic piety is only
to encourage ultimately The Cutting of
our own throat culturally politically
societally thank you thank you
[Applause]
I find myself in some difficulties here
I love debates uh but I usually debate
either pro-choice people or
atheists and that's a knock him down
drag himount debate between myself and
my
enemy uh Bob's a good friend a fellow
Catholic not an
enemy uh so I view this more as a
discussion than a debate
uh a kind of inhouse theological
exploration between two friends only on
the ping pong table are we
enemies and he didn't tell you that by
the end of one semester he was beating
me 50% of the
time uh I also find some difficulty in
the fact that this is the first debate
I've been ever in in which I had the
left chair I'm usually somewhere to the
right of a the hunt
a third difficulty is
that that Bob knows much more about
Islam than I
do uh it is a minor interest of mine uh
and usually when I say something about
Minor interests even though it's true I
get in
trouble especially about controversial
issues like the sexual Revolution or
homosexuality or
Islam uh my final difficulty is that I
agree with almost everything Bob up said
tonight all right we're done
except one little question in the spirit
in the spirit of Columbo or
Socrates one last little
question almost all your premises are
true but do they really entail your
conclusion seems to me you have two
conclusions two main points and I
disagree with both of them first is that
the only good Muslim is a bad Muslim the
second is that Islam is a greater threat
to us than the
enlightenment so those are the two
things I'd like to focus on I'd like to
make very clear that my standards of
judgment are exactly the same as
Bob's uh first of all the magisterium of
the Catholic Church uh secondly basic
human reason thirdly the facts of
history and experience which can't be
denied
uh since my ultimate standards of
judgment are Catholic I'd like to start
not with my own opinion but with the
quote opinion of the Catholic church for
the first time in 450 years the church
has issued an official Universal
catechism and there is a paragraph in it
especially about Islam just one but I
think this paragraph is just about the
most important quotation we could use
about
Islam it's it says paragraph 841 the
church's relationship with the
Muslims The Plan of Salvation also
includes those who acknowledge the
Creator in the first place amongst whom
are the
Muslims these profess to hold the faith
of Abraham and together with us they
adore the one merciful god Mankind's
judge on the last
day now I think Bob would agree with
that first of all he's a Catholic
secondly nothing he said contradicted
that but I would like to Simply add to
what Bob said rather than contradict it
because that's a Hal Truth uh I don't
think he uttered Any Lies uh and I don't
think he uttered any false judgments
except his two conclusions but there's a
lot of other things to
say uh first of all the only good Muslim
is a bad Muslim uh I know that isn't
true because I've met some good Muslims
who are good and not bad I've also met
some bad
ones uh the only good Muslim is a bad
Muslim means that quote a good Muslim
unquote is a
self-contradiction somebody who is
utterly faithful to Islam and the Quran
and there are many different
interpretations of it there's not just
one Islam as there is one Catholicism as
you know there's no magisterium for all
the Muslims in the world they're like
Protestants uh they're all over the
place uh
well not quite as bad as that they're
not 28,000 different sex and
denominations
uh but just as all Protestants believe
the Bible all Muslims believe the Quran
that's a a textual Unity rather than a
magisterial Unity
uh let's say there's three different
levels of Islam that we have to
distinguish first of all there's the
level of terrorist activity which none
of us here fors in the least we
abominate that that is there's
absolutely no excuse for that all right
secondly there's
islamism there's the imposition of
sharia law on everyone there's the
refusal to make a distinction between
the church and the state there is the
identification of religion with politics
which all good Muslims share not all
good Muslims justify terrorism in fact
most of them in the west profess not to
but I have never met a Muslim who
believes in the separation of church and
state
uh and therefore the notion of universal
equal human rights for people of all
religions is not the ideal of any Muslim
in the world including good Pious
Muslims that I'm
defending so I certainly disagree with
them on those two levels but there's a
third level namely personal
piety and on that level I think we can
learn a lot from Muslims I think they
can sometimes put us to
shame uh especially the suis
who although they're not Mainline
Muslims and although they are labeled by
most Muslims as unorthodox are
nevertheless pretty universally
respected for their piety and if you
read the writings of some of the sufis
you find among some flaky stuff some
very profound
stuff uh so it is simply not true that
the only good Muslim is a bad Muslim let
me tell you a story about a good Muslim
um
the character here hea Ben Adam is based
on a combination of idealized features
of some Muslims I've uh met or read
about and my own imagination but one of
them was a graduate student at Boston
College who I had in a course in
comparative religions and he he always
sat next to uh a Jewish student who I
think was Orthodox because he had a
beard and a yamaka uh and
dreadlocks uh and they fought all the
time over Palestine of course they
almost came to blows but they sat in the
front row and asked most of the
difficult questions and I love them for
it because I love
troublemakers uh as long as they don't
use physical violence and they didn't
quite use physical violence although
they shouted a bit uh and the rest of
the students about 24 of them were
Catholics uh at least nominally in some
stage of descent or Ascent uh you know
Boston
College it used to be a Catholic college
now it's a Jesuit college
actually they're not so
much non-catholics who think they're
Catholics they're really Hindus who
think they're Catholics because they're
all pantheists they think God is
everything uh that's a surprising result
of questionnaires you find out amazing
things about your students when you ask
them questionnaires instead of just
teaching them anyway uh it was time for
the break and we learn more during the
break than during my lectures uh so I
gave them a long break and we were
munching on potato chips and drinking
Coke uh and U the uh the Jewish student
whose name was zi noticed that behind my
head on the cinder block wall there was
a faint cross painted there so he said
that's supposed to be a cross I turned
around and looked and I realize that
that was where the crucifixes used to be
before they were taken down so I turned
around and I was about to in a
shamefaced sort of way try to give some
lame explanation for the fact that the
Jesuit took the crucifixes down uh When
U the Holy Spirit closed my mouth and
opened the mouth of the student next toi
and said oh that's where we used to have
the crucifixes before we took him down
in a very proud and self-satisfied sort
of way and so I said I thought he was
going to say when why did you take them
down he said when did you take them down
said why is he saying when so the
student scratched her head and said U
last semester I think what
month February I think aha said sety it
was the Bundy
money what's that well so I explained
that MC George Bundy was the Secretary
of State under either Johnson or Carter
one of the presidents and there was a a
course that was going to a case that was
going to come before The Supreme Court
as to whether it violated the separation
of church and state for Catholic schools
to receive government
grants uh and the president didn't want
that to come before The Supreme Court
for some reason or other so he had a
secretary of the state help State
negotiate an outof Court settlement
According to which the answer was yes if
and only if the school was not sectarian
divisive or exclusionary whatever that
meant it was vague enough to satisfy
everybody Z pointed out that in the
semester following that ruling every
single one of the 21 Jesuit colleges and
universities in America took down their
crucifixes oh my God is that a
coincidence he
said
H uh so the Catholics none of the
Catholic students knew that and they
were kind of embarrassed and one said we
wouldn't do that for money
it's it's why andv smiled wickedly and
said of course not but I hope you got
more than 30 pieces of silver this
time half the students didn't get it
so they're biblically illiterate you
know they're not Protestants they don't
read the Bible so so Z turned to the
said you see the first Catholic to
accept a government grant was Bishop
Judas
scariot so they kept saying no we
wouldn't do that for money we did that
to be
ecumenical at this point uh the Muslim
chimed in and said what's the meaning of
ecumenical he directed the question to
me I was the expert so I opened my mouth
and for the second time I was about to
utter some sort of answer to his
reasonable question when again the Holy
Spirit interrupted me closed my mouth
and opened the mouth of a student next
to him who was another Catholic student
who gave a really stupid answer to the
question e medical means we all love
each other and we're all equal and here
comes everybody and we didn't want to
offend anybody something like
that so the Muslim said oh you didn't
want to offend anybody uh oh we didn't
want to offend others oh others you mean
like me the Muslim and my friend the Jew
now they were
friends and as soon as the two words
Muslim and Jew were pronounced everybody
got very quiet as if a blasphemy or an
obscenity had been
uttered those are very concrete words
they have teeth in
them so the Catholic Student said uh
yeah so the Muslim said well you have
offended me what yes you have offended
me by taking down your
crucifixes why have we offended you
you're a Muslim you don't believe Jesus
died on the cross Muslims said you took
down your crucifixes to avoid
uh offending
me
uh you have insulted me why have we
insulted you suppose you came to my
country I think it was Iran not even
sure you suppose you enrolled in a
Muslim University knowing that it was a
Muslim University now we don't have uh
pictures of Saints or statues we think
that's idolatry but when you were in a
Muslim University you know that you are
in a Muslim
University uh you may see quotations
from the Quran
uh would you be offended at seeing a
Muslim symbol in a Muslim University of
course not said the Catholic who would
only a bigot correct yes now you expect
me to be offended at a Catholic symbol
in a Catholic University so you expect
me to be a bigot I am highly
offended they were very quiet I could
smell the wood
burning then comes the important part he
didn't he didn't stop at that he turned
around faced the class like a
fundamentalist preacher and he said how
many of you believe that Jesus Christ is
the Son of God I said to myself who is
this Jerry fwell in
disgu is this guy a Muslim is he from
Central casting or
something uh so they they sort of
gradually put their hands up in a very
embarrassed way and he said well I don't
believe that I'm a Muslim the Quran says
that's blasphemy that's ridiculous
that's absurd it is
awful Allah has a son the the very m
mountains cover their ears before such
blasphemy but but as a Muslim I love
Jesus Don't Call Him Christ well
actually he does he they do he's the
Messiah he's the Messiah but uh we don't
call him the Son of God uh we call him
one of the greatest men who ever lived
and the Quran says nothing bad about him
it says that he performed Miracles he
raised the dead he was virgin
born uh the Quran even has Allah rebuke
Muhammad and say you must repent of your
sins it doesn't say that about
Jesus and the Quran also says that Jesus
will come at the end of the world to
administer the last
judgment so we Muslims have a a a deep
love of the Prophet Jesus blessed be his
name and like Muhammad we never say his
name without saying Blessed Be he or
peace be upon him uh now if we had
pictures of the Prophet Jesus in our
classroom we would never take them down
not for anything not for money not for
Prestige not even if soldiers from the
government came into our classroom with
fixed bayonets and said there has been
regime change there is a new law you
must take down the pictures of your
Prophet Jesus every good Muslim in that
class would get out of his seat go to
the front of the picture of the Prophet
Jesus and say you take down the picture
of our beloved Prophet Jesus over our
dead body we would be glad to be a
martyr for his honor and now you take
down the pictures of your beloved
Prophet Jesus simply to get money from
the government so I think perhaps we are
better Christians than you
are I was the only one
smiling I said Thank You Holy Spirit for
sending a prophet outside Israel into
our
midst now in the Old Testament God does
that very
frequently he sends pagans either to be
prophets or to be wise men or more often
to be
military uh generals who smash the uh
the Jews and and teach a lesson they're
they're agents of
God uh I think therefore since I believe
everything in the Bible that it is quite
likely I know Bob will disagree with
this it's quite likely that one of the
reasons why Islam is growing so fast
especially in Europe and Canada and
America that is in what used to be
called Christendom which is now apostate
Christendom or Western Civilization one
of the reasons is that God fulfills his
promises and one of the promises he made
in the Bible is that he will bless
everyone who obeys his laws and he will
not bless anyone who disobeys his laws
now there's one very basic law that
Muslims throughout their history have
disobeyed very badly Thou shalt not
kill and Christians have a mixed track
record there and it it's not a track
record to be proud of but it's not
certainly not as bad as the Muslim track
record but if you look at all the other
Commandments especially the one that
characterizes our society the most
namely Thou shalt not commit
adultery I think you can see why the
Muslims are being blessed why are they
conquering Europe they tried to do it by
force of arms for a thousand years they
couldn't do it now they're doing it why
well because they found a weapon much
stronger than swords it's called
mothers they are having children they
are deferring gratification they're
paying it forward they are respecting
families uh and we aren't
there's the the fruit of the
Enlightenment of rationalism
individualism
secularism
uh if I had to choose therefore between
uh a
Muslim and a secular
humanist defender of the sexual
Revolution
Enlightenment person for instance Boston
College Theologian uh I would certainly
choose the Muslim
to say that Islam is more our enemy than
the than the enlightenment is to say
that people who believe in love and
worship the one true God even though in
ways that are defective and very
seriously defective are worse than the
people who don't believe in God at all
that doesn't make
sense how much time do I have left
minutes two minutes okay
our primary enemies are not
Muslims our primary enemies are
demons According To Jesus
Christ according to St Paul we wrestle
not against flesh and blood but against
principalities and
Powers throughout our history we've
forgotten that and we have confused who
our enemies are whether it's Protestants
or Communists or Muslims or whoever uh
we have tried to convert Souls by
killing bodies now we don't do that
anymore and that's good but what we've
substituted for that we used to act more
like Muslims that is uh what we've
substituted for that unfortunally is a
kind of indifferentism and oh come on
let's just get along and it's not really
that
important which I think is
worse indifferentism means you don't
even play the game you don't even take
truth
seriously at least you don't take
religious truth
seriously playing the game on the wrong
side believing a religion that has very
bad things in it as well as very good
things in it a heretical religion which
is all the other religions other than
Christianity I mean every religion has
some very good things and some very bad
things in it Buddhism for instance they
have a wonderful sense of peace and and
and and mind control and a terrible
theology there's no God at all they're a
pantheistic pudding uh
to to say that our our fundamental
enemies are people who on a very deep
level believe in love and worship and
try to obey the same God although in a
much more primitive way in a much more
barbaric way and through a a heretical
Communications network but one which
borrows enough from Judaism and
Christianity so that the attributes of
Allah the 99 Names of Allah are all in
the
Bible to say that they are more our
enemies than our own
apostates uh that strikes me as
absurd I debated an atheist once at the
University of New Hampshire they didn't
know who I was and the atheist was one
of these analytic philosophers who
thought the word God was meaningless so
we didn't get to debate whether God
exists until the last 15 minutes we
spent most of the time my trying to
defend the meaning of the word God and
describing what God's attributes were uh
so I thought it was a bad debate
afterwards a Muslim came up to me and
said said uh you teach at Boston College
I said yeah he said you're a Muslim
aren't you I said no I'm a Catholic oh
oh I was confused why were you confused
well your theology is perfect you know
Allah
exactly now at that point I'd never even
read the
Quran uh it is obvious that the
catechism is right we worship the same
God in very different
ways uh and there are very serious
differen es between Christianity and
Islam and I don't want to minimize them
at all and therefore I agree with almost
everything Bob said but let's get a
sense of perspective our real enemies
are well who is jesus' Real Enemy is it
Caesar is it the Roman soldiers or is it
Judas
scariot once we get the Judas es scariot
out of the church I think we may be able
to convert Muslims and I would love
nothing better than to convert
Muslims but the way you convert people
is by Holiness by
sanctity now if if we could meet on a
fair Battlefield here uh in which the
weapons were not swords but
Hearts if if we could send Saints to
Muslim countries and they could send
Saints to our country and we tried to
convert each other by the power of
sanctity that would be a wonderful
battle because nobody
lose and I think we'd win more Hearts
than they would
thank
[Applause]
you well I understand Dr CRA that uh you
uh your points about that the
enlightenment is a greater enemy and
that we need to uh have some kind of a
convergence or a uh cooperation between
people with a shared morality MH and and
so I suppose uh what I would ask you is
how can we find an accord
when there are elements of Islamic
morality itself that are so deeply
problematic for example Muhammad when he
was 54 consummated a marriage with a
9-year-old girl and as he is the
excellent example of conduct that is
something that is considered normative
such that the AI when he took power in
Iran lowered the legal marriageable age
of girls to nine and uh when the aid
workers went into the refugee camps in
Afghanistan in 2003 they found that half
the second grade age girls were already
married and virtually all of the girls
older than that were already married so
this is something that is uh essentially
rampant and very hard to eradicate you
mentioned also adultery and uh of I I
think about Islamic marriage law and the
fact that a man can have four wives all
he has to do is say tck you were
divorced and she's gone and he can get
another as well as uh sex slaves that
he's conquered in battle which is
specifically allowed for in the Quran
4:3 uh and so there there's a kind of an
appearance of morality that uh I'm not
sure really squares with the kind of
morality we might want to form some kind
of a Cooperative Venture with people who
hold uh and so I would wonder for
example also in in closing I don't mean
to drag out the question too much but uh
I remember uh the great Oriana falace
who was an Italian journalist
internationally famous who uh wrote two
very very popular books about the
islamization of Europe after 911 and she
was a great hero for freedom and for
human rights I had the great privilege
of knowing her toward the end of her
life and she told me that when she
interviewed she did a very famous
interview with the Ayatollah Ki and she
was preparing for the interview with the
translator in a room in ton before they
went to meet Ki and suddenly a mullah
burst in and said it's a scandal it's
terrible you're not married and you're
in a room alone with a man and so he
forced her to marry the translator they
have in Shiite Islam temporary marriage
which is essentially uh usually not in
Fat's case but usually prostitution uh a
marriage contract with a deadline you
can marry somebody for an hour or for a
weekend and then it expires and you're
not married anymore and yet so in other
words the appearance there's no adultery
sure why should there be at least for
men but it's not really anything that I
would say is really preferable even to
Enlightenment anything goes morality
which is a a Corruption of
judeo-christian Standards uh how can we
square that with the idea that there
should be some sort of a of an accord
between moral people we can't however uh
I don't think most Muslims would defend
that although that may be
wrong uh I think it's parallel to our
attitude toward the
Mormons uh can we tolerate polygamy
certainly not but most Mormons don't
like polygamy anymore either and most
Muslims don't in fact especially in the
west have more than one wife either it's
like can we tolerate uh African animism
no can we tolerate polygamy and Africa
no the church has a big problem with
that nevertheless we can still learn
something from the Mormons we can learn
something from the Africans we can learn
something from the
Muslims uh George wiel says that the
Catholic Church could get its social
agenda through Congress if it did just
one thing kick out every single Roman
Catholic and replace them with a Mormon
or a
Muslim in some areas they
are better than we are at preaching and
practicing morality in other areas
they're
horrible but we can still learn
something from them and the thing that I
try to point out in this book that we
can learn from them uh it's a difficult
concept it's it's not formulable in just
one concept really it's a it's a set of
Concepts I call it the
Primitive uh certainly Muslims have a
more primitive concept of God it's not a
god of love it's not a trinitarian god
it's not a God who has a son or uh who
does an Incarnation or who who who saves
you uh it's it's a very early Old
Testament God
but if we don't if we repudiate those
roots entirely as the enlightenment does
we don't we don't really have a god at
all uh here's a passage from chesteron
from St Thomas
aquinus uh and this I think we can learn
from Muslims because and we better
because we've forgotten it it's a
defense of the fear of God as the
beginning of all wisdom which most of
our religious teachers say is a very bad
thing and the beginning of all
foolishness but it doesn't say that the
fear of God is the whole story it's just
the beginning of the story the fear of
the Lord that is the beginning of wisdom
and therefore it belongs to the
beginnings and is felt in the first cold
hours before the dawn of civilization
the power that comes out of the
Wilderness and rides on the Whirlwind
and breaks the gods of stone the power
before which the Eastern nations are
prostrate like a pavement the power
before which the Primitive prophets run
naked and shouting at once proclaiming
and escaping from their God the fear
that is rightly rooted in the beginning
of every religion true or false the fear
of the Lord that is the beginning of
wisdom but it is not the
end now if religion is an organic thing
like a tree uh and if this primitive
fear of God is its roots and if we have
detached from our own roots and if a
religion like Islam is clearer and
stronger about those roots even though
it has corrupt branches we can learn to
our own use some things from Islam about
those roots you can learn the same thing
from from primitive Africans do you have
a followup oh sure
uh there
are certainly things that we can learn
from any any uh given individ ual there
are certainly wise people in all
religious Traditions that's really I
think not an issue here uh the question
before us is the the only good Muslim is
a bad Muslim and you mentioned earlier
that you you know that there are good
Muslims who are good Muslims because
you've met them and I think well sure I
I know good Catholics who contracept and
yet they will tell you that they are
perfectly good Catholics and they're
completely observant uh this is of
course in defiance of Catholic Church
teaching and there are other people who
would say well no you're not actually
good Catholics and how is one to
determine that you go to the sources you
go to the teaching of the church and so
I would submit that you only know a uh
whether a Muslim is a good Muslim or Not
by Islamic standards and we have to look
at what their own texts and teachings
say and so for example the very Charming
story that you told about the crucifix
and the pictures and the uh Muslim
student there are several very not not
things that I I think ought to be added
uh for our edification tonight one is in
Islamic tradition Jesus will indeed come
back at the end of the world not
Muhammad but Jesus will return at the
end of the world and he will break all
the
crosses that's Islamic tradition in
other words he will destroy Christianity
which is believed to be a perversion of
the true teachings of Jesus and so he
will break all the crosses kill the pigs
because of course the Christians are the
ones who eat the pork and abolish the
gizia the tax that I mentioned before in
other words he will destroy Christianity
and islamize the world that's obviously
one of those people that St Paul
mentions in Corinthians when somebody
comes to you with another Jesus other
than the one we have preached to you you
receive him readily enough but he not
the Jesus certainly in remotely of uh
the New Testament and further in regard
to the pictures while I I applaud and
appreciate this gentleman saying that he
would protect a picture of uh uh who he
terms the prophet Jesus and would re in
other words these religious figures
actually unfortunately his
co-religionists in the Balkans in
particular in in Serbia Croatia Bosnia
herova there are their video tapes you
can find the tapes on YouTube of them
going into churches going into uh
Orthodox and and Byzantine Catholic
churches and kicking down the icons of
Jesus and of his mother and burning the
church pulling the cross down off the
top destroying the any any
representational art now which one of
these is really the good Muslim well
Islam does teach that representational
art particularly of prophets and
religious figures is a blasphemy and
ought rightly to be destroyed and thus
the people who are actually being the
pious good Muslims were the ones who
were destroying the pictures of the
icons of Jesus and his mother in the
churches in the Balkans this is true
this is true but my my Muslim student
did not would not deny that but he said
if we had pictures which we don't which
we regard as Blasphemous and idolatrous
if we had pictures we would defend them
to the death now that's that's similar
to and here's my question for you what
do you think about this the same student
once asked to go to mass with me uh and
I was surprised and he said don't get me
wrong I I have absolutely no intention
of of becoming a Catholic or even
interested in this but it's it's pure
curiosity but but I I I promise to be
respectful so we went to mass together
and he just sat there like like a stone
he wouldn't move he wouldn't rise or
kneel or or in any way cooperate but he
was very quiet and respectful uh and
afterwards I said well what did you
think he said two things that impressed
me the first thing was U this was in St
Mary's Chapel which is a beautiful
little Stone Gothic Chapel in the BC
campus uh he said uh how old is this
building I said well it's over 100 years
old the first building on the BC campus
back in the 19th century and he said how
old are the words that the priest
uttered
I said well half of those were his own
interpolations and half of them and half
of them were a sort of revision of the
church's liturgy which was retranslated
a couple of years ago but the the
structure of the mass goes back to the
beginning but the actual words are
fairly modern words he said I thought so
I said why I knew he knew nothing about
Catholic tradition he said well uh when
I looked at the building uh the stones
brought my spirit
uh closer to heaven but when I listened
to the words they were like shallow
babbling Brooks simply moving
horizontally on the earth I thought that
was rather perceptive and then then he
said uh do you do you
Christians really believe that Jesus is
literally the Son of God I said yes the
Orthodox ones do the modernists don't
the Liberals don't but yeah both both
Protestants and Catholics believe that
and he said and the different fure
Protestants and Catholics is you
Catholics also believe that when that
priest holds up that little round piece
of bread that really turns into Jesus
literally I said yes he said and that's
why everybody got very quiet then I said
yes that was worship that was
adoration uh and I said I I know you
think that's blasphemous and ridiculous
uh and Protestants do too except for
anglicans and lutherans who believe in
the real presence uh by the way one of
the things that made me a Catholic I was
born and brought up as a as a calvinist
uh was reading the church fathers and
how they never questioned the real
presence for a thousand years I said how
could how could it how could God allow
such an error to exist in the church for
a thousand years I mean bowing down to
bread and worshiping wine thinking it's
God that's really bad uh so he said so
you Catholics believe that that is
really Jesus and Jesus is really
Allah fully Divine I said yes and he
said oh I don't think
so and I said well I don't expect you to
believe it it's a difficult thing to
believe and of course you're a Muslim
you don't believe that he said that's
not what I mean I I I I I I'm I'm I'm
not I don't want to tell you what I mean
it's too embarrassing so I I tried to be
nice and said well I I I I suppose you
mean you can't ever imagine uh doing
what the other people did the Catholics
namely getting down on your knees before
what seemed to be merely a piece of
bread he said no that's not what I mean
uh he said I tried to imagine myself
believing that which I of course never
would it's Blasphemous but I don't
really think that you believe it why not
well and and he stopped again he said I
don't want to insult you I said I have
thick skin try so he said so I said you
you you you can't imagine yourself ever
getting down on your knees and he said
no I can't imagine myself if I believe
that ever getting up off my knees
again now there's a ser seriousness
there there's something there directed
to a wrong object the wrong religion
which I think we can learn some profound
lessons from well that's that's actually
the question before us then uh the
question is not really are there Pious
Muslims or are there Pious people who
are Muslims that's manifest that's
obvious that's uh that's easy the
question before us as far as I
understand it is whether Islamic piety
is something that really is in accord
with the best elements of the human
spirit and which exalts the human Spirit
or rather whether it degrades It
ultimately if somebody follows it up rly
agree that the answer to that question
has to be neither a simple yes nor a
simple no because there are obviously
ingredients in Muslim piety that no
Christian can applaud or agree with and
other ingredients in Muslim piety
equally important and equally Orthodox
which every Christian must agree with
well I guess you know what I would say
Islam itself the very heart of the
religion total submission and surrender
to God that's the formula for a saint
yes absolutely and as you very aely
pointed out in your book that's
something that is common to Judaism and
Christianity it's not something that was
originated in Islam and so actually I I
find myself agreeing I must say with the
Byzantine emperor Manuel poos who was
quoted so famously by Pope Benedict the
16th a few years back touching off
worldwide riots and murders of innocent
people when he quoted him saying uh
there's nothing that Muhammad brought
that was new or original
that was not
inhuman and uh I don't remember the
exact quote but something like that
there's evil and inhuman nothing that
Muhammad brought that was new and
original that was not evil and inhuman
there's plenty of good in the Quran
that's taken from Judaism and
Christianity where it becomes
problematic is where it departs from
that now we can see that because we're
standing outside it and we understand
probably most of the people in this room
know a great deal about Christianity and
maybe some of you a great deal about
Judaism as well and of course Judaism
and Christianity come from the same
Wellsprings and are very similar in many
important ways now that is something
that we know then when we see these
elements of Islam that they are uh
separable conceptually from the rest but
for Muslims these things are all a whole
like you mentioned for example the sufis
and said the sufis have a wonderful
spirituality they do have a wonderful
spirituality in my first book Islam
unveiled I quote in its entirety a poem
written by The
ayatollahi Who was very deeply
influenced by Sufism now the aahi also
said that I Spit on the foolish Souls
who believe that Islam is a religion of
Peace he didn't have any trouble having
these mystical flights that exalted his
soul and also thinking that it was part
of the muslim's responsibility to take
up arms against unbelievers and there
was no separation it was all part of
what he considered to be the devoutness
of his observance they also the sufis
for several hundred years have been at
the Forefront of the Armed Jihad Warfare
in Chia against the Russians and Hassan
Alana the founder of the Muslim
Brotherhood who I mentioned before was
very influenced by the sufis and as he
is establishing this violent arm of
political Islam he prescribed various
Sufi exercises for the early Brotherhood
members of the Brotherhood and so uh to
also Al gazali the one of the foremost
sufis in history is very very clear that
Jews and Christians must be fought
against and
subjugated uh he had no trouble con
conceiving of these two things together
and so once again I have to come back to
the topic the only good Muslim is a bad
Muslim is a reference it's a perhaps a
little bit of a course and insulting way
to put it as I'm explained before but
nonetheless it contains a truth and that
is that there are elements of Islamic
piy that are not separable from the rest
that are deeply embedded within the
religion itself in the core teachings of
the Quran
and of Muhammad that lead one not toward
God and not toward any authentic
spirituality but toward absolute evil
would you agree though at
least that there are things in Islam
that they have learned from Jews and
Christians not new things the emperor is
perfectly right that we have forgotten
and that therefore we can relearn from
them in so far as they are elements
already of the jewi and Christian
Traditions then certainly uh we should
look to any PI people and say that piety
is a good thing and ought to be fostered
yes uh I'm not sure we need to go to
them to ReDiscover that kind of thing I
there's plenty within our own Traditions
that would
uh that would do that for us if we would
simply recover those yeah okay I don't
think we disagree about very
much I'll see what I can
I'll see what I can do about
that I'm the SE of discourse Discord uh
not discourse SE of discour is good yeah
no Discord um okay first I would like to
ask and and after my questions I'm going
to O open to the audience I'd like to
ask Mr
Spencer when we say if you say the only
good Muslim is a bad Muslim presumably
you mean good as in good for us as
Christians living in the West in other
words
what good as in to our benefit to our
safety to our free Pro promoting our
freedom our ability to worship
evangelize live in peace um
but if you hope that Muslims are not
true to their own religion and are not
true to their own conscience then aren't
you hoping that they are disobeying the
the voice of conscience and therefore
damning their own Souls isn't that a
perverse thing for us to hope for and
isn't it a little crass for us to hope
that Muslims go to hell just because it
makes them less likely to kill
us
I I don't accept the lally uncomfortable
question yes it's a wonderful question
but I think it's there's a bit of
sophistry there uh I don't
think that God would ever that that that
that the the the true living existing
God who is God of all the creation
would ever condemn someone to hell for
doing evil that he thought was the right
thing or doing the right thing that he
thought was evil there is absolute good
and abs there is absolute good and
absolute evil these things are clear
these things are actually uh uh
relatively Universal across religious
Traditions with a notable exception of
Islam in the abolition of man CS Lewis's
book uh he has at the uh is an appendix
as of course I know you're aware a uh a
a listing of various quotations
establishing what he calls the Dao the
way which is uh what he is explaining
are universally held moral principles
among Christians Jews Buddhists Hindus
Etc very notably absent are quotations
from the Quran and from the teachings of
Muhammad that would support these
otherwise Universal moral principles of
Thou shalt not kill Thou shalt not steal
and so on and so on uh Islam does uphold
those things but for Muslims only uh
there is uh in other words pretty much
you can say all of the things that
people say in the media about Islam are
true if you add four Muslims at the end
like Islam is a religion of Peace for
Muslims Islam is a religion of tolerance
for Muslims and so on so the the point
is that when we're talking about people
following their conscience there is the
there's a great danger I think a worst
danger the the the danger of Hellfire
for anyone is to become convinced that
to do evil is good and thus we should do
everything we can to try to show them
that that is a demonic deception
amen like to respond to his
answer or not I think it is very
probable that it is indeed a demonic
deception and I think it is very
probable that the Quran is a mixture of
three things
it claims to be a divine
revelation uh it could conceivably come
from three and only three sources the
human the Demonic or the
Divine uh in the Catholic tradition
private Revelations are not infallible
the devil loves to mess up private
Revelations to confuse even the Saints
and to get whatever falsehood he can in
with truths it seems to me uh in the
Quran you have a mixture of divine
revelation at least influenced by if not
totally derived from Judaism and
Christianity uh but maybe maybe God sent
an angel to Muhammad to get some
messages through and maybe a few of them
got through I don't know sorry are you
saying that Islam is is on the par of a
private Revelation like Fatima or Lords
no no certainly not but I am saying that
there may be
some Supernatural good as well as
Supernatural evil in the experiences
that Muhammad claims to have had in that
cave mixed with Muhammad's own very
human uh proclivities to a mixture of
Good and Evil which would explain the
mixture well I don't know you know I I
go back to the cave and the Very
earliest Hadith the earliest Traditions
about Muhammad are all about what
happened to him in that cave and it's
very fascinating because if you were a
Muslim going to Muslim school to to uh
learn about Islam then you would learn
that the angel Gabriel Muhammad was
praying in a cave and the angel Gabriel
appeared to him and told him to recite
and he recited that's what Quran means
recitation and over the next 23 years he
was given recitations to recite that
were the words of God the word of God
the perfect and Eternal Word of God that
it existed forever with God in paradise
and was then being transmitted to Earth
through Gabriel to Muhammad now that's a
very nice story that's sort of the
Sunday school
version or we could say the the Friday
school version but in the actual Hadith
about the
incident the angel is not named as an
angel or as Gabriel he is some sort of
spiritual being who then presses
Muhammad very hard on his chest so that
he thought he was going to die and tells
him to recite and he says I can't I
can't read because he was thinking I
have to get a printed text and then or a
written text and then recite it and he
presses him even harder and all the
breath is going out of him he's like a
cosmic Thug pressing on Muhammad forcing
him saying recite and finally Muhammad
says okay okay and he goes home he's
shaking with fear and he says to his
wife cover me with a blanket he's he's
he's shivering and he says woe is me
either poet or possessed by Poet he
didn't mean Rod mccuan he meant like
somebody who is receiving ecstatic
demonic
visions and
so is that really the kind of story that
we would expect if it was Gabriel
the one who appears to the Blessed
Mother in the Gospel of Luke and tells
her that she's going to be the mother of
Jesus it's very different kind of story
it's a very different character of story
and I think that in itself is very
telling and
revealing it sounds suspiciously like
some of the disturbing stories in the
early parts of the Old
Testament okay good and now okay good
now we're all really Disturbed and
unsettled uh
I don't know that there's really any
comparable story in the Old Testament I
I I appreciate the Jacob wrestling with
the
angel Jacob wrestling with the angel
what does the angel do to him that would
terrify Jacob into thinking he's
demon-possessed he breaks his hipbone he
Jacob doesn't go home and say I think
I've just been demon possessed does
he all right now I've got a question for
Professor creef um couldn't we learn
what we need to learn from Muslims by
reading their books
but nevertheless energetically fighting
their attempts to assert themselves in
American society restricting their
entrance into our countries and just
generally fighting political Islam and
redu committing our protecting our own
religious freedom and our own political
Freedom by aggressively imposing our own
values on our own societies uh in other
words not permitting them polygamy not
per committing them honor killing or
wife beating or any of the other aspects
of sharia that they that they claim to
be asserting in some cases trying to
insert into our legal the legal system
of Great Britain in other words couldn't
we get all this from your book what your
book tells us what we need to gain from
Islam and so okay fine they can go home
now the long and complete and nuanced
version of of my answer to your question
is
yes we might all actually agree more
than we
realize yes but on the other hand on the
other hand I would not
necessarily condemn the idea of a
foundation who which arose and came up
with this flaky
proposal uh The Clash of civiliz ations
Islam versus the West could be at least
mitigated if not overcome if we simply
spent some millions of dollars buying a
fleet of planes and using them for a
kind of a double transportation system
let's take all our pop psychologists and
put them in Muslim countries and let's
tell them to send us some fiery mulas to
give us some
spine I like that I like that idea
better than the one that that uh prime
minister Netanyahu once expressed in the
knesset that we that the they should
translate Sex in the City into Persian
and drop the DVDs all across
Iran you know it's it's it's which a
tempting idea I have to say but that's
my mellan side well what the mulas would
do if they were imported here I mean
we're already seeing uh what's happening
uh so I don't think that that really uh
would necessarily be a good idea uh but
it's interesting to note also in terms
of secularism and Islam that that uh a
lot of people have the idea that uh and
this is absolutely germine to our Point
here tonight the only good Muslim is a
bad Muslim it might not even be so that
a bad Muslim is a good Muslim because uh
secularism has often been posited as an
antidote to all this and people say Well
they're so they're so Pious and their
piety leads them into dangerous and
violent directions and therefore we have
to make them less Pious so we'll airlift
Sex in the City into uh Iran or whatever
uh but actually you know American
culture is already there uh and there is
plenty of uh uh Sex in the City all over
the Islamic World make no mistake uh
Charles Glass who was an American
journalist who wrote a very fascinating
book called tribes with Flags uh in
the80s he uh was actually the book
tribes with flags is an account of his
crazy decision to walk from Antioch in
southern turkey to Cairo
down Lebanon into Israel all the way
down and of course in Lebanon he was
kidnapped by his Bala and held as a
hostage and while he was there uh he uh
found that his captors were listening to
Michael Jackson records and Madonna and
that kind of thing and they would come
up to him and they would say do you
think American girls would find me
attractive and meanwhile they're holding
the kalashnikovs on him you know and and
then they pray
andbar and they're going to slit his
throat uh but incidentally he had you
might want to read that book it's very
interesting it's it's a straight
journalistic kind of account of what
happened but then at the end it gets
very interesting because he starts
having visions of the Virgin Mary who
tells him how to escape from his
captivity and he does follow her
directions and escapes I have been told
by numerous missionaries most of them
Protestants that something is happening
in the Islamic world in the last few
decades days that has never happened
before conversions to Christianity are
happening and almost every single one of
them has to do with a vision of the
Blessed Virgin Mary yes yes that's uh
there are visions of uh Mary that have
appeared and been seen by really many
thousands of people it's phenomenon zun
more more people saw that Miracle than
any other miracle in the entire history
of the world yes 2 million in Cairo
standing on top of a church yes Muslims
and Christians together
the Blessed Virgin Mary so yes something
is happening and she unlike you was
making peace
signs oh I'm all for peace but I think
that uh peace without a realistic
appraisal of the situation is just naive
and could be suicidally naive I agree I
to
agree the only the only thing that you
said tonight other than your your
conclusions that I disagree with and I
think it was just as of the tongue was
you spoke of absolute good and absolute
evil now God is certainly absolutely
good but even the devil is not
absolutely evil because God created
him so how could his La be worse than
the devil I I I let me give you uh I I
don't want to speak about the devil but
uh he doesn't interest me but chapter
91:7 of the Quran says that God places
Evil Within the heart of
man which is markedly different from the
Christian idea that uh that evil is the
absence of God's presence in the soul
and evil is a rejection of God not
something that God actually actively
encourages but the Bible also says I
create good and evil evil there being
death and suffering rather than moral
evil rather than sin maybe the Quran
means that well we could we could trade
versus wait wait wait can we can I think
are are you referring to the question of
Free Will in Islam I think that's
something that's just where I was going
to go chap 32:13 of the Quran said uh
Allah says we he always speaks in the
Royal we even though he's an absolute
unity and he says if we had
willed we could have guided all men to
the truth but instead we will fill hell
with gy genies and
men so we in other words he's saying he
could have this is this is the the god
of Islam speaking saying I I could have
brought everybody to a knowledge of the
truth but I I just want to fill up hell
but like like Augustine most Muslims
also claim to believe in free will as
well as infallible predestination I
don't know where you're finding them
because actually the Quran decisively
rejects the idea of Free Will and says
repeatedly that Allah leads astray Those
whom he Wills does not allow to go
astray but he leads astray Those whom he
wills and guides Those whom he wills and
then this verse that I just quoted to
you is also echoed in 7: 179 which also
says I will fill hell
with men he could have decided to do
otherwise but he has decided to condemn
certain people to a very ldly and de uh
lovingly lavishly described vision of
Hell in the Quran and he's sending them
there because he wants to perhaps Dr
creef I can ask you as a as a former
calvinist um in the reagens BG address
Pope Benedict was talking about
commonalities between Islam and the
Calvinism in their rejection of the idea
that we can reason about God because
analogy does not apply to God we cannot
reason about God there can really be no
Theology and uh Pope benck was talking
about this as a kind of the beginning of
the secularization of the western mind
um it it seems to me that when the
Muslims rejected the mutaz light option
when they rejected philosophy they
rejected aich they rejected avaros at
the same time Thomas aquinus was taking
these thinkers and trying to reconcile
faith and reason the Muslims CH saw an
irreparable divide and ins superable
divide and they chose faith and in
opposed to reason it's Pope Benedict
seemed to be saying that with Calvinism
and with the Reformation the long
process began of the West rejecting
faith and only accepting reason so in a
sense is is there some sense in which
Islam and the secular West are kind of
mirror image of each other two broken
pieces of a puzzle that's very
profound who didn't make it up the pope
made it
up I'm trying myself for remembering it
Robert Riley's Robert Riley's recent
book the closing of the Muslim mind is
very enlightening on that yes it is a
desperate philosophical mistake it's
volunteerism and nominalism it's
aism yes yes all
right are there questions from the
audience okay I'm I'm seeing a parallel
with the sufis in you're putting the
their piety that you look to them for
and the Pharisees and their piety which
was really uh you know dirty drags it
was because the inside was corrupt and
so that's that's what I put to you is
the Sufi piety even the go goel writers
didn't say the only good Pharisee is a
bad Pharisee in fact there were good
Pharisees Nicodemus was one of them
Joseph and Fara was one of them gel was
one of them St Paul's teacher here you
have three very good Pharisees although
many of the Pharisees were Wicked
people okay um I'm going to go one other
further
um here
um both yoube from Mr Spencer um we know
that politics is a is a practical are
often brings together um strange
bed and factions and coalitions of
groups and persons who would ordinarily
be opposed to each other from that
purely practical
standpoint um couldn't we say that the
Christian West and Islam whether Muslim
individuals or uh political groups or
nations can that we can make a deal with
the devil so to speak and cooperate with
them in the United Nations uh on the
global front to fight the kinds of evils
that Dr C was talking about well I don't
have any objection to doing that
obviously it worked in Beijing and uh I
think the only Hazard of it is that
people don't recognize the limitations
of it uh here again I'm all for peace
but we need to go into such things with
open eyes and understand that we are
dealing with a group that will never
regard non-muslims as as their equals
and will not regard us as uh any more
their friends because we have cooperated
on these various Ventures than they did
if we had not
cooperated uh there's a great in other
words uh you know I think for example
the American military's idea of going in
and handing out candy on the streets of
Baghdad and Cobble and and and uh
basketballs and and and going in and
building hospitals and schools and Roads
and all that it's all great uh but the
it's predicated on the idea that we will
win over their hearts and Minds by doing
that whereas the as if for example they
hate us because we aren't being nice to
them and or they hate us because of our
immorality or they hate us for whatever
whatever other reason when actually if
you go back to the Quran it says fight
against the Jews and Christians not just
the immoral Jews and Christians or the
Jews and Christians whose foreign policy
you dislike or something like that just
fight against the Jews and Christians
and so there is ultimately for a Muslim
who takes that
seriously ultimately no Accord is
possible unless we submit or convert so
certainly some sort of limited
partnership is obviously possible
because it's happened if we're shrewd
about it though shrewdness is is is very
good in this case
yes one second I'm checking the time
okay um
um gentleman in the back in the blue
shirt we often times uh hear in the
media when there's an event such as what
took place at Christmas Day bomber Fort
Hood that a Muslim has been
radicalized uh to either of one or both
uh what is it that radicalized
them well I know how Bob's going to
answer that question they haven't been
radicalized because Islam is essentially
radical uh they haven't been turned into
radicals from beginning by being
moderate
Muslims rather moderate Muslims probably
began by being more radical Muslims and
then softened their religion and that's
probably historically true uh but we
certainly can hope for a softening of
Muslims it has happened before in
history it can happen again because
Islam is like protestantism it has a
Bible but there are so many different
interpretations of it possible without
an infallible
magisterium that there are no preset
limits to emphases and interpretations
that could be in the future uh I don't
personally hold much hope for a a
moderate and liberal Islam suddenly
arising In Our Lifetime but uh it's not
in principle impossible so I think we
should encourage any movement in that
direction can I I wanted to C what would
sof what softens Muslims well in the
first place I actually did want to
answer the question which was what
radicalizes them you it's generally an
appeal to quranic texts and teachings
it's generally a call to say you are not
being a good Muslim unless you do this
chapter 9 ver 111 of the Quran offers
Paradise actually guarantees Paradise I
should say to Those Who Kill and are
killed for a laot and this is used today
by Suicide bombing recruiters to get
people to strap bombs on them M El and
they go kill some infidels they get
killed in the process they're guaranteed
a place in paradise and that's a very
powerful inducement if you really
believe that this is how things work now
what would soften these things I
wouldn't say that it's impossible but
Islam we should know in the first place
it's not really like protestantism at
all protestantism as far as I understand
it operates on the principle of the
Bible alone is the authority and so
anybody can read it and come to a
different view because no book
interprets it self but at this in in
Islam there are authorities there there
the of various countries the religious
Scholars of various countries who issue
fatawa which are rulings that are
considered binding upon those within the
jurisdiction there are uh the schools of
jurist prudence the madid there are
eight of those nine of those rather uh
incidentally eight of those nine uh do
admit to the uh utility of artificial
contraception and so that's something
that they differ from the Catholic
Church of about uh at least the teaching
of the Catholic Church the um
the teaching authority of those schools
of jurist prudence is considered to be
binding upon the Muslims to who adhere
to one or the other of the schools
although it's not a matter of conversion
or some kind of rupture if one moves
from one to the other they're regionally
distributed and generally if you grow up
in one area then you interpret the Quran
according to the teachings of these
various schools as I said before there
is no sector school that doesn't teach
the necessity to wage war against
unbelievers and subjugate them could
there arise some kind of Islam in the
future that didn't teach that or
actively rejected it I suppose anything
is possible but it would have to come
with a wholesale rejection of konic
literalism and that means in other words
that they would be considered by
traditional and mainstream Muslims to be
bad Muslims right they would have to be
like Jesuits at Boston College exactly
maybe the Jesuits can help soften up the
Muslims uh the gentleman back there yeah
but is it the is it the uh the real
problem the fact that Europe doesn't
have enough of uh you know they can't
replace themselves and the fact that
Europe will probably end up being Muslim
within 30 years and that Germany will be
totally Muslim within 50 years isn't
isn't that the real real problem and uh
you know going to uh you know it's just
that it seems to me that you know I mean
what Peter K says that you know well I
bring the student here he he understands
he you know he he's the church with me
and he and he's respectful and then I
think about what happened two days ago
is it or three days ago in in Iraq I
mean is is slaugh cathol church who who
was there you know in uh with Peter K I
don't know 20 years ago 10 10 years ago
is it possible that he could be back
wherever he is and he might even been in
the church you know two days ago that's
the problem I think with uh you know
that we we have with the Muslim faith is
there a question well I guess the
question is how do we how do we address
that which part of it uh the part is
that we they're schizophrenic I mean
here they are in in the United States
they're perfectly uh uh because uh it's
it's it's part of the faith that says
when you're outnumbered to be a pacifist
when when they're when they're amongst
themselves when when when they're in a
group they seem to lose
control so how do we handle that what
what what is what is our philosophy how
do what is what how how do we how do we
address that practical problem okay well
yes I I would like to amplify just a bit
a couple of these points uh because Dr
Craig said earlier that most Muslims in
the west don't practice polygamy and
don't practice these other uh elements
of the faith that we would consider to
be noxious uh and I think are
objectively so uh actually that's not
entirely true there actually is uh even
by uh most recent accounts I believe uh
was it 20 or 30,000 polygamous couples
in the United States polygamous families
that is polygamous groups uh that uh are
Muslim and it was very noteworthy that
Ibrahim Hooper uh of the Council on
American Islam relations which is a
Hamas linked Muslim Brotherhood front
group that masquerades as a moderate
organization uh hi ibraim um Ibrahim
Hooper actually said uh in in response
to that news item about polygamy in the
United States he said yes there is uh
polygamy among Muslims in the United
States and they uh Islamic scholars
differ as to whether it's permissible
notice he didn't say anything about
American law making it
illegal he didn't seem to care about at
all it was only the Islamic scholars and
also just today in uh uh Seattle was it
Seattle no San Diego I'm sorry one of
those s cities out west uh he there was
a cleric an Islamic cleric a preacher of
nonviolence and tolerance well regarded
in his community named Muhammad Muhammad
Muhammad I'm not making that up and
Muhammad Muhammad Muhammad was arrested
today for aiding the Jihad in
Somalia uh and so uh yes what are we to
do about this now uh now that I have
just made the made the question worse uh
well first thing we have to do is assess
it realistically and understand that uh
really the anybody who professes the
Islamic faith if he delves into the
teachings of his own religion is
somebody who could end up being very
dangerous to us now that doesn't mean
that people should be rounded up and put
into camps or any of this nonsense but
we need to enforce our own laws about
sedition and to formulate some sane
immigration policies and recognize that
this is an
ideological conflict and not some sort
of a problem of racism or all these
things that usually Cloud these issues
may I ask you a question certainly which
do you think is worse in the eyes of God
Muslim polygamy or the fruit of the
Enlightenment by which we say that a man
can marry a
man well see both of them you know it's
very interesting that in your book uh in
Dr Craig's book he has a chapter about
marriage and writes very movingly is as
he can do so well about uh the nature of
marriage and he has the Muslim uh
expatiating upon the nature of marriage
and the respect that a that a husband
should have for his wife and the respect
that a wife should have for her husband
and so on and so on the the interesting
thing to note however is that that is
not the concept of Islamic marriage at
all
in Islamic marriage the woman is
essentially chatt and actually the the
word for for marriage in Islam is an
obscenity in Arabic I'm not making this
up but the theological term for marriage
in Islam is a word that people don't say
in polite company oh and it's because
it's it's really a very degraded idea
and so I I you ask me which one is worse
I I think that both are deviations from
the kind of uh mutual respect and mutual
self-giving that the Catholic Church
Enis Visions as marriage but doesn't the
Quran also say that you may have four
wives but only if you can respect all of
them and do justice to all of them it
doesn't say respect all of them it says
you can have I happen to have it right
here it says you can respect you can
have four wives if you can treat them
all equally in other words if you if you
treat them all same if you're beastly to
all of them then you can have you could
interpret it that way it doesn't say
anything about respect yes first of all
I'd like to say that it's nice to be at
a college uh to be able to have a debate
on Islam where the faculty and the
students are not outside shouting
obscenities that's what usually happens
when I speak in col
we saved that for the
classroom I was I was at Temple
University in Philadelphia just last
month and there were protesters outside
shouting about racism and how I was such
a terrible person so loud we could
barely hear hear ourselves in there uh
so what I would like to um address is
this growing uh Allegiance between
radical Islam and not only the American
left but the global left I iCal left in
general and a couple recent examples is
when Bill ory went on The View left of
center show and he mentioned that we
were attacked by Muslims Joy bear got up
and walked out and then right after that
Juan Williams was fired from NPR for
saying that he gets nervous when he sees
Muslims getting on an airplane and
that's I'm sure something most of us
innately feel and and so I'm trying to
figure out you know if you guys have any
thoughts on on this growing you know
because I feel I'll beat anytime I want
to speak about Islam in public and
sometimes honestly I feel like my life
might be in danger because of it so why
why the alliance well I would like to
point out that uh Al Qaeda has Al-Qaeda
has issued a fatra against Mr Spencer
he's the number four on their list of
Americans with a bullet
yeah so that's why he has a bodyguard
here tonight um but I would like both of
you to be able to respond to that why
would would the left feel an affinity
with Islam it seems bizarre to us do you
have any insights
Professor yeah because the left wants to
feel an affinity with
everybody except us ex
ex the left hates
America and because the left hates
America and they see that the the the
the Islamic jihadists hate America they
see a friend there and they see somebody
they can cooperate with and also the
left doesn't understand
religion doesn't take religion seriously
and thinks well yes they're nutty
religious people but we can control that
we we'll take care of that after we've
defeated the Real Enemy Den Dua wrote a
book called The Enemy Within yeah one of
one of the worst books I've ever read
one of the
best all right it out now I I heard
debate uh Alan wolf at Boston College uh
and it was the most one-sidedly
embarrassing debate I ever heard and
Boston College censored the debate and
refused to allow the tape script out
because D totally demolished Alan wolf
who is a classic liberal who says we're
all equal why can't we just get
along well certainly I I uh I wasn't at
the debate I have debated Desh myself uh
you can see the uh debate on YouTube if
you're interested we were debating
because DES contends in his book The
Enemy at home that essentially Britney
Spears calls 911 uh
that uh the American American pop
culture going into the Islamic world
made these straight laced moral people
rise up and strike back against us that
of course completely ignores and I don't
think Des is even aware of the fact that
they were fighting jihads against us
before pop culture was immoral and uh as
a matter of fact it's noteworthy that sa
kutub uh the uh one of the key theorists
of the Muslim Brotherhood came to the
United States in 1948 and spent 2 years
here in Colorado and he wrote about his
experiences with America and how they
hardened him in his uh understanding
that America had to be destroyed and
that it was this deeply immoral
principality and uh in 1948 you know
Doris Day was on the top of the pop
charts uh the the idea that uh that that
kind of thing was immoral it perhaps
betrays the fact that actually if you
look back even in Crusader literature
you find that uh the Islamic World
generally always thinks of the Christian
world as immoral and the immorality is
ultimately beside the point because as I
said before the teachings of Islam say
fight the Jews and Christians it doesn't
say leave the moral ones alone and only
fight the immoral ones it says fight the
Jews and Christians is the difference
then between the Muslims and the
Christians that during the
Crusades uh Muslims put chastity belts
on their men and it said make war not
love
I think that I think that in Latin is
the slogan of the
college Mr Harry a question from an
actual Thomas Moore student one we got
one into the room Mr Sten Harry um I was
wondering um what
differences uh are there between our
concept or a Christian concept of
ultimate beatitude or heaven and
the Muslim concept of that and what
effect that may have on motivations like
you mentioned earlier um to lose your
life or take a life for Allah I'm it's
an embarrassingly yeah I'm going to let
him go first so you can respond
okay I'm think being fa here uh charl
def Fuko who of course uh is is blessed
now is that right in any case uh shuko
lived in North Africa and was killed by
uh by jihadis there but the point is
that earlier in his life before he
dedicated himself to uh that kind of
life in North Africa he essentially was
a libertine and when he looked at the
Islamic idea of paradise and he con he
he uh first encountered Muslims and the
quranic teaching about paradise and and
and the afterlife he said well he had
tasted those pleasures and he knew they
were not the ultimate good and not the
ultimate joy and ultimate happiness and
so he knew that Islam was not the true
Faith because he knew that the soul
needed something else but the Islamic
vision of paradise is just as you may
have already heard it's essentially what
you might expect a 14-year-old boy in
Arabia to dream up as being the highest
good uh lots of girls uh lots of cool
breezes lots to drink uh it's you know a
pleasure Palace this is why they come to
Boston College you
well you could I I don't I wonder why
they don't go to Vegas you could start a
very successful nightclub and call it
Muslim paradise and uh I it would be a
very Pious very Pious place I think I
think when when the pious Muslim gets to
Paradise he will indeed find 40 virgins
but they will be
nuns there's a great picture of 40 Nuns
with
guns even all that's been said here I'm
curious um if I can hear maybe both of
both of the panelists uh speak to what
our our public policy should look like
with respect to Muslim practice in the
United
States I mean I don't
I no no question evenhanded equal rights
uh no no privileges no nothing special
here's American law it is not
specifically Muslim or anti-muslim
Christian or
anti-christian it's based on universal
human rights if they don't like it too
bad
I mean jokes about about enforcing not
enforcing s laws and there was I I I
would I I would I would support the
right of Muslims to build uh a mosque or
a Muslim Center by 911 I would also
support the right of an anti-muslim
jewish organization to to write put a
temple right next to
it in Saudi Arabia I I believe
absolutely in uh in in human rights and
United States Constitution and that
Muslims should be accorded all those
rights uh that doesn't mean however that
these supremacist initiatives including
the triumphal Mosk at Ground Zero uh
should be allowed that's not really a
religious religious freedom issue at all
it's a question of whether a mosque like
the Dome of the Rock built on the side
of the Jewish temple or like the AL of
Sophia converted from the grandest
church in Christendom should be allowed
to Mark the victory of the Muslims on
911 which is how it will be understood
in the Islamic world but that's side
issue what should we do in terms of
public policy Dr CRA is Right enforce
our laws and uh not Accord any special
rights which Muslims are pressing for
today in all kinds of ways to Muslims or
anyone else and if we did that then a
lot of this problem would be solved
there's also an example I think for us
in how the MacArthur occupation
government in Japan after World War II
treated State Shinto Shintoism was the
militaristic fuel that fueled the
Japanese war machine the mil istic
ideology and after World War II when
MacArthur was in charge in Japan he said
Shintoism is an individual religious
Faith should not be interfered with at
all but Shintoism will have no place in
the government or in making public
policy with any preference to any other
with with with preference over any other
group wasn't part of your wasn't a ma
major frust of your argument that
um that Orthodox Muslim practice kind of
GES like this bad behavior yeah and so
what you have here is a situation where
we have to understand that there are
elements of Orthodox Muslim practice
that Muslims are going to have to give
up in the United States because they are
not in accord with American law and that
is not something that is without
precedent and it is not something that's
against the first amendment I look at
Mormon polygamy which has come up
already the United States government did
not hesitate to Outlaw polygamy even
though it was a religious tenant of the
Church of Jesus Christ of Latter-day
Saints and this was considered to be
something that was in the National
interest I don't think that's in in the
least incompatible with the First
Amendment to understand that there are
certain elements of Islam that Muslims
must not practice in the United States
because they are against the national
interest and in contradiction with the
freedoms guaranteed to us by the US
Constitution all right Mr
do from a Thomas More student who is
joining the Israeli Army next year
[Applause]
not our part of our RC
program um slau I I was wondering if uh
you can answer this for me and so I'm
sure you're probably at least familiar
with the supremacy clause in the Quran
that says that in order to honor Allah
you must kill all the infidels first The
Saturdays and then the Sundays so how is
it that you justify the statement that
it would be easier to work with
Enlightenment Enlightenment then uh when
their view is inherently when Muslim
view is inherently U contradictory and
to uh judeo-christian values where the
enlightenment view is not okay no first
you had a clarification yeah I did want
to point out the Quran does not say uh
to kill all the uh infidels it says
actually it says kill the mush which are
the polytheists those who are commit
Sher Association of partners with Allah
usually but not universally Jews and
Christians are not considered to be
musun they are considered to be uh
people of the book and the people of the
book have a third option they don't have
to be killed or converted they can be
subjugated as demies uh ultimately
however there is a Hadith that is very
pernicious where Muhammad says this is
not in the Quran it's a Hadith but he
says the end times will not come
until Muslims kill Jews and the Jews
hide behind trees and the trees cry out
and say oh Muslim there's a Jew hiding
behind me come and kill him now that is
an authenticated Hadith that is one that
is considered to be part of Islamic
Doctrine and so it is considered to be a
laudable practice for a Muslim to kill a
Jew because it's something that hastens
the coming of the end times in which all
things will be
consummated but anyway it's not
specifically in the Quran like that
that's all did you want to respond
well most Muslims in the west do not in
fact believe or practice that uh and I
suppose Bob must be right in saying that
if everything in the Quran must be
accepted literally and practiced then
these are bad
Muslims so in that sense I agree with
him that the best Muslim is a bad Muslim
we have
agreement now we're going to sing
Kumbaya
our School fight
song I would like to thank you and we're
out of time I would like to thank you
all for coming and asking such
intelligent questions and crowding in in
these Potato Famine coffin chip like
conditions uh for for such a long time
thank you very much and thank you to the
speakers for